[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show for we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality and at number one
best-selling author host of the Ken
Coleman show where he talks about jobs
and careers every day is my co-host
today so we'll be talking about that and
your life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're going to start this hour with
Selena in Orlando Hi Selena how are you
hi I'm doing well I'm really excited to
be talking to you great how can we help
um so I I recently I'm married I'm 28 I
live in Orlando and our household income
is 155
000. and we just had a baby and we were
living in a really small condo and kind
of needed more space really quickly so I
was through all of my 403b about twenty
six thousand dollars to cover the down
payment and the closing costs I think
when we sell our current home I'll get
about 26 to 30 000 back
um but now I'm I'm a new listener and
realize I'm kind of going didn't follow
any of the baby steps and I'm just
wondering what advice like you would
give us um in terms of having a bit of a
higher mortgage payment now and then
also needing to kind of rebuild
retirement or starting a bit from
scratch
ouch
well it's not got anything to do with
the baby steps you've screwed yourself
um you've really made yourself a mess
because if you do not uh redeposit the
26 000 within 60 days of the time you
took it out you're going to be charged
your tax rate plus a 10 penalty on this
and so you're going to lose 40 percent
of that money in taxes and penalties
okay translation
thirteen thousand dollars
twelve thousand dollars is going to
government
okay
so when you sell your house you need to
set aside enough to cover the mess you
made when your tax bill comes next year
um and then the rest of that money will
be used for
uh wherever you are I guess in your
situation but yeah this uh you borrowed
money for a down payment at forty
percent interest is what you did
okay yeah I was hoping like with the tax
thing like this like we'll have a baby
on there and this is the first year
we'll be filing like you can't offset
this level of math okay babies don't
babies don't cover this
no okay not even close so this is yeah
you really stepped in it um so oh my
gosh uh how long ago did you pull the
money out
um
let's see we're in July so maybe about a
month ago
but um the the house that we're having
built won't be done until end of
September and so I'm trying to time the
selling of this house at the closing why
did you pull the money out if you
haven't closed on your other house
I needed the money for the down payment
so you put the down payment first and
then they for them to start building and
then it's not a down payment it's a
deposit
okay yeah so I had to put five percent
of the of the house five percent of the
cost of the house I had to give that to
them in order for them to start building
it yeah and then if your house doesn't
sell now you got two house payments and
you're double screwed
the other houses in the town home have
been going for like 30k more than what I
originally paid for it and so I'm hoping
to get like a bigger when this house
does sell yeah if interest rates took up
a point and by September by the time you
get your house on the market and the
market freezes like a deer in the
headlights you've really messed yourself
up I'm scared for you honey I'm scared
um you guys have done you guys got
completely impulsive and you impulse the
house and it may it made itself a mess
potentially I hope you get out of it
with your skin intact but I'm not
positive you're going to so anyway what
can we do from here uh I assume you gave
them twenty six thousand dollars right
I gave them 16
okay so you have ten
yeah and then I had savings already so I
have about 17 000 in savings
Plus 10.
no to 17 in total I had seven already oh
you had seven okay all right and you
don't have any other money
[Music]
you have Investments of any kind that
are not mutual fund or that are not uh
retirement accounts
um I maybe uh three months ago I opened
up a 529 for my daughter how much is in
it
probably about three thousand okay
because every dollar we can put back in
that 403 b before the 60-day Mark is not
going to be taxed or penalized and so
I'm going to scrape nickels out of the
corner of the couch and try to get as
close to 26 000 back in there because
every dollar you put in there is going
to save you 40 cents
you follow me okay ten thousand dollars
if you can put ten thousand dollars in
there saves you four grand
and the four grand is just burned up
it's just went to mist it didn't it
didn't accomplish anything except to
allow you to buy something you weren't
ready to buy
and didn't need to be buying but you're
there now so yeah you need to scratch
together as much as you can and put it
back uh go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on smartvestor and find a
smartvestor pro that helps with
investing in your area that we recommend
and they'll help you try to get this
undone and get as much money back in
that account before that 60 day Mark as
you can to keep from getting hammered
with a 10 penalty plus your 30 tax rate
40 cents on the dollar okay now then the
rest of this is we're gonna have to put
you on a game plan where you got to stop
buying things you can't afford
and uh and buying them out of order
because you just and you justify it with
a lot of emotion because you had a baby
babies don't take up that much room
they're not that big
and so
this is just complete
normal stuff I'm not mad at you honey
I'm scared for you and I really want you
to not have a mess because by this time
next year if you've got two house
payments and a 13 000 tax bill all
because you bought a house and can't get
your house sold you got a mess on your
hands you've set your family up for a
real problem here unless you unless this
just unfolds perfectly for you so let's
get with a smart investor Pro and get
this turned around I say Dave I'm
following you would you suggest that you
didn't say it so that's why I'm asking
pulling the 3000 out of the 529 adding
to every dollar I can find so it's not
in a retirement account in this case
she's got 17 in savings she puts the
three on top of that she's at 20 does
she keep a thousand in it baby so now
we're at 19. how does she come up with 7
000 in 30 days before she gets penalized
only on seven thousand not on twenty six
thousand I like this and so if it's if
I'm hearing you and I hope you're
hearing this Selena I mean we got we
need to get your budget on a and rice
thing and start replenishing your your
savings account very very quickly but I
like getting taxed on seven versus
twenty six taxes and penalized at 40
percent on it all yeah wow so yeah this
is this is you do not use your
retirement account people yeah you do
not use it for anything except
retirement because in the in the
system's designed to punish you yeah
beyond belief if you do and it ain't
cool here it ain't cool it's not okay
you know it's not funny it's not fun
it's then there's no rationalization you
know babies don't take up that much room
slow down sell your house when your
house sells take that money buy a house
if you want to build a house then take
that money move into an apartment and
use the money from the sale of your
house for your deposit on the new
construction but
um yeah you got sucked into new house
fever bad instead of taking a cold
shower you got yourself in a mess ah I'm
sorry hun this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show thank you for
being with us America Tanner is with us
in Washington D.C hi Tanner how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up
so my question is I'm curious about the
flexibility of spending more than 30
percent of your take-home pay on rent
found that pretty difficult to do
especially in like an urban area like DC
I live in downtown
um I make around 90 000 a year in close
grad 23 year old
um I've got about 20 000 in cash and
seven thousand uh in an investment
account and
finally my only debt is around seven
seven and a half thousand in student
loans and I spend about two thousand
dollars a month in rent which is my
biggest expense expense by far but I
still find myself able to save
um and spend less on other things I'm
just curious your take on
on that approach okay well we tell folks
to put 25 percent of the take-home pay
aside for housing and uh no math Works
in every city and in every state you
don't get a pass on math because you're
in Washington DC even though Congress
thinks you did yeah I was getting ready
to say a lot of people think they do
yeah a lot of people in DC think you do
but you don't uh and the purpose behind
it is not that 25 is Magic Tanner uh the
purpose behind it is don't be house poor
if you find yourself able to save and uh
able to invest because you keep all
other parts of your lifestyle so low
then then you're okay but if you're you
but what happens to most people is when
they've got a high cost of housing in
their budget it squeezes their budget
and there's not room to save up to buy
the next car so the next car becomes
debt and there's not room to save up for
Christmas and Christmas becomes debt and
there's not room to save up for a couch
and the couch becomes debt and because
it's all going out in house payment and
so in effect what you did is you uh you
you didn't you know by by squeezing
yourself you did that now you're telling
me you've made room in your budget and
you're doing okay then you know if
whatever you want to do brother but
here's the thing whatever you spend on
rent
is gone
I mean you're setting fire to 100 bills
in the middle of the floor and so the
more hundred dollar bills you burn in
the middle of the floor the fewer month
less money you got man I mean it's a
pretty simple equation
yeah yeah that's definitely uh
definitely reduces the about ability to
buy down the road for sure yeah yeah I
mean because you're giving it to them in
rent and so I don't know how you fix
that exactly necessarily in your
situation maybe your commute is longer
maybe there's a roommate involved or uh
or maybe you just say I'm gonna it's
gonna cost me this and it's my choice
and I'm an adult well yeah you're
allowed to do all that but our reason is
to give you giving you the 25 guideline
it's not a rule it's a guideline it's so
that you don't become house poor because
if you're for instance going to get a
mortgage folks in America
um this stupid mortgage company will
approve you for almost double that
I mean they'll approve you close to 50
percent of your take-home pay 36 percent
of your uh ratio you know and so and
that's not based on take-home pay the 36
that you can get a house payment up
close to half of your dad gum take-home
pay and there's just no way that budget
Works people and well I'm in California
well California they got to do math too
even though your Governor doesn't think
so you've got to do math you know it's
not it's not an option math is math and
it's not it's not a a moral construct
it's a it's a math thing well to win
Tanner in professional World Financial
World you've got to sacrifice everybody
who wins has to sacrifice something and
what we've done here with this 25
percent you are now having to choose do
you want to sacrifice money as Dave said
by by burning those extra hundred
dollars between the five percent that
we're talking about or do you want to
sacrifice a little bit of your time now
you're living downtown DC that's premium
and I get it you may work on the hill
who knows what you do but you're there
for a reason but if you move out into
the suburbs of Northern Virginia I know
it well yes it's a it's a headache but
we rather you sacrifice the right thing
and that's why we put this I want people
to understand what we're teaching here
it's not to be hard and fast on a rule
it's to help you learn what you need to
sacrifice and in my situation if I were
in your situation Tanner I would be
sacrificing my time not my money yeah 23
years old yeah yeah you know I will tell
you this Ken I did it worse than he's
doing it sure worse yeah he's in good my
wife and I get out of college and here's
how stupid we were
we go and rent eight we we have two dogs
we're just out of college I've got two
little jobs
we go and rent a three-bedroom
townhouse sure luxury right thanks sure
that's like
five times what we needed because we
thought it was cool do you remember what
were in the extra rooms uh nothing sure
because by the time we finish paying the
freaking rent we had no money yeah so
what we ended up doing was moving into a
little one bedroom uh apartment in a
questionable uh I don't know what those
ladies down the hall were doing in a
questionable situation and um you were
hoping you weren't on a Vice episode man
I'm telling you and uh we lived there
for a year but it was one third the rent
that we were paying before one third
and so that'd be like you you had an
1800 rent and we moved down to a 600
rent right you know kind of thing today
in today's dollars it was a lot less
than that in the back when the dinosaurs
roamed the Earth but yeah but oh my gosh
wow I did the exact same crap no I get
it but I wanted something nice and I had
a job yeah and I'd gotten out of college
and I'm I deserved it but a lot of 23
year olds that are in a very similar
situation Tanner now just think about
this if he gets a roommate
and now he's saving let's just call it a
thousand dollars a month
okay splitting the rent he's paying off
that student loan debt of seven thousand
dollars really really fast and now he's
just stacking money
stacking cash man so much more than
renting uh paying all that money rent
Tyler's in Louisville hi Tyler what's up
um yes I had a quick question first of
all you guys are awesome thank you
uh so I have a I'm on baby step two and
um been doing ish for a while and at the
beginning of the year I got smart and
said you're stupid get out of debt
um with the student loans coming back up
because I've been basically taking that
payment towards everything else mine is
Consolidated or I believe it is at least
because
um do I look at the individual loan
amounts or do I just look at the
Consolidated amount where I put it out
if it's Consolidated it's now one amount
okay it used to be little nouns if it is
one loan
I mean if it's a bunch of little are you
paying will you be paying a bunch of
little payments or one payment no I pay
one payment and when I look at it I see
all the individual ones I took out yeah
but that doesn't matter but it's the
purpose of that snowball is you want to
what what you want to have happen in the
debt snowball is you want to
um
clear a debt and that payment on that
debt to go away when you clear one of
these little debts it doesn't change
your payment
all right that's what I was thinking I
wasn't sure yeah um so I would just put
the total in your debt snowball
awesome that works hey man thank you sir
get after it that's really smart because
you know the data is now coming out now
that we're actually finding that that
you're going to have to pay your student
loans which we've kind of been telling
you for three freaking years but um now
that we found out that we were right
again
um yes I just said I Told You So live
with it
um but now that we found out you have to
pay your student loans there's gonna be
a lot of questions about student loans
and we're one of the things we're
finding uh Jade and I were talking about
this earlier is that
people uh basically took the money that
they would have been paying on student
loans and spent it yes they did on
vacation vacations alcohol
drugs this is this is the actual surveys
are coming back I went on a party nice
yeah with the money that the taxpayers
told me I didn't have to pay right now
because you were in a covid crisis
anybody remember what covet was yeah it
was there it was just a minute ago but
it was a crisis if y'all didn't remember
and it was such a crisis that nobody
could pay their student loans but they
were able to use the money that they
would have been paying on their student
loans and go buy drugs and alcohol and
Vacations so apparently it wasn't too
big a freaking crisis
what do I know um
just going with the data here
's what happens when you trust a
politician with an empty promise that's
not constitute someone from the medical
community that's trying to do math
which is proof that we've proven that
you know once America got a fouchied we
figured out what happened this
is the Ramsey Show
man
foreign
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author of the book from
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five thank you for
joining us America in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions on the debt free stage
Jared and Christina are with us hey guys
how are you thank you how are you
welcome where do you guys live Woodstock
Georgia about 40 miles north of Atlanta
yeah well well welcome to Nashville not
a bad drive up here not bad good to have
you so how much data have you two paid
off 136
000. all right and how long did this
take you seven years to the day that we
bought the house ah okay and what was
your range of income during that seven
years uh we started about 60 and ended
about 145. cool what do you all do for a
living I'm a mechanic for the Post
Office and I'm a constable manager at
Kennesaw State University awesome yeah
all right she got a little bit of a
commute down there
actually it's only nine nine miles from
me oh okay all right not bad all right I
missed I messed up all right so uh 136
seven years sounds like you paid off
your house yes all right look at it
weird people way to go you guys what's
this house worth
3 45 now I'm sorry 3 45 3 45 awesome
very cool so how much do you guys have
in your retirement savings already
I think we're at about
I know last year last year was a little
bit of a
everybody's but yeah okay so you're
gonna be about a half million dollar net
worth already so you're on your way to
be a millionaires in no time way to go
that's fun I just said that out loud you
hear that wow that's pretty stinking
cool guys so what starts you on this
journey seven years ago
so I actually started um when we first
got married 15 years ago we just
celebrated our 15th year anniversary
congratulations and so our first year
you know I'm actually not originally
from here so we um knew each other in
person from before and then uh when I
moved here it was really the first time
we did anything together and then we got
married
um in the July of 2008 and it was you
know the year a great year to get
married so we pretty quickly
um figured out that you know our
finances are will need some um
Improvement pretty quickly we had a
little bit of debt I grew up living
pretty frugally and so we had some
arguments and by the end of that year we
knew we we sold the car that he had some
um debt on and then when I got a job we
actually paid all of our debt our
biggest issue was
um the underwater Mortgage in the for
the town home that
um was purchased in 2007.
so you know we were kind of bopping
along for a couple of years a week then
we had kids and I ended up staying at
home it was pretty tight
um and we were still kind of trying to
figure out where what are we going to do
about the house eventually this has
still not come up to the value that it
was and at some point we got an email
from our church we go to Woodstock City
Church
um introducing Financial Peace
University
and in there I was like ah you know I'm
pretty for a goal I keep my budget
um you know after the fact that got on
the track of what was spent
but it said it will show you how you can
buy and sell a house so I'm like you
know why don't we take this class
um so
when we went and took the class I was
like you know where have you all been
before
so we did quite a few
um things followed quite a few things
um one of them was um we immediately
refined that house to a 15 so that we
could start paying um down the the what
we owed on it
and um
from the seven percent interest rate yes
I had been paying off yes essentially
our payment stayed the same oh you know
more was going yeah so you went down to
what a three uh it was up four at the
time in um 20 it was 2013.
um and so
yes 2013. I contacted one of elps we
loved her Lindsay Haas um a shout to her
she came out because we knew we couldn't
sell the house right away so she showed
us what to do you know it was just uh
um you know she didn't charge anything
for that so we started over the next
couple of years we started doing some
upgrades to the house like we painted we
redid the not redid the deck but we
cleaned up the deck and all of them some
other stuff and so when the time came in
2016 we were still kind of figuring out
where whether we're staying in the area
or whatnot and then our HOA was kind of
going down the hill we decided it was
time to put it up for sale
um again Lindsay helped us through that
process she was a great selling and um
buying agent there were several um
offers on the house that we were looking
at to buy
um and
um we had had enough equity out of
gotten out enough equity out of the
house and we had had some savings or
rather from a sale of an apartment that
I had back home I'm not originally from
the US and it was about 20K so we were
able to put 20 out like you um teach yes
she not only got out of the bad town
home bad HOA that had been upside down
but you were able to put 20 down on the
New Deal
yes and then seven years later you paid
it off and now it's worth 3.45. yes you
got to feel like a genius
we bought two cars cash during this time
while we were paying this house off yeah
wow another shout out I wanted to do to
Rachel I remember her talking about how
you know if you want to because I wanted
to get a change in the career and so I
went and took classes at a smaller
College you know not a four-year College
because that we could cash flow at the
time and then now that I work at KSU I
went ahead and finished my bachelor
degree that
um with you know they pay for it they
pay for it right and I'm working on my
master so quite a few accomplishments
along along the way
um so how does it feel I want people who
are maybe new to this program going they
paid their house off that was the debt
what does it feel like to not have a
house payment now and then as you look
toward the future it's sinking in it's
still not really hit us but
there were several people I worked with
that were like oh you need to not worry
about that you need to buy this and buy
this and go have fun and you can worry
about that later you've got time before
retirement and now I've had several guys
come up to me shake my hand like we're
proud of you good job that's cool
um they kind of see it can be done now
yeah so yeah and Christina you really I
mean you upped your game on your whole
career that's a nice move it's a very
nice move so what was the increase in
your pay because we looked at the total
you guys went from 60 to 145 how much
did you increase so that was incremental
um I started this full-time job in 2018
I was looking at you know numbers and we
actually averaged about 108. my latest
promotion was in January to the manager
position that was senior account how big
of a bump was that for you
um
14 yeah but you know the previous year I
went to senior accountant which that was
about 15. she goes it gets the goes and
gets the education that is that she can
afford in her budget and then goes to
work for a college and they give her
free to finish her Bachelor so there's
there's a path here called common
freaking sense way to go I'm so proud of
you Heroes thank you excellent job what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is
stick together talk it through be in
agreement
um
you won't always see eye to eye on
everything but work through it yeah make
sure you make sure to get to that point
yeah every morning you know I am the
nerd he's the free spirit in the sense
that you know I
worry about my spreadsheets but every
Sunday we get together we sit and we
just talk you know we dream and so
um you know his one of his hugest
contributions that he's actually worked
um over time for the last 10 years six
days a week pretty much every week so
it's there was a lot of you know it
wasn't easy no how old are you two
um 41 today yeah and you're great happy
birthday thank you and uh and you got a
paid for 350 000 house and I'm 44. yeah
and you know you're on your way to be a
millionaires in no time congratulations
we're so proud of you Heroes well done
Heroes all right bring the kiddos up
give us their names and ages and while
they're coming up we've got a baby steps
millionaires book for you a Total Money
Makeover book for you and a Financial
Peace University membership for you you
can use them or give them away that's
the live and give box we'll have that
for you thanks for coming up to do your
debt free scream so what are their names
and ages this is Greg he's 11. this is
Kira and she's 10 and a half all right
they have no idea yet what their parents
have done to change their family tree
pretty incredible guys you guys are
awesome all right Jared and Christina
Greg and Kara from Woodstock Georgia 136
000 paid off in seven years house and
everything
making 60 to 145 count it down let's
hear a debt free Scream one two three
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it's done I love it she goes
back to school with Community College
yep Upshur game goes and finishes her
master goes and finishes her bachelor's
UPS her game well done guys and he works
overtime like crazy that's right this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Ken Pullman Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Billings Montana hi Shiloh welcome to
the Ramsay show
thank you for having me sure what's up
my question is my husband 's for a
company that is unionized
actually going to be striking fairly
soon and
um my question is do we hunker down and
wait and ride it out or do we work on
paying off our debt still what what's
the best solution to do
uh it depends on the probability of the
strike and let's talk that through for a
second
okay sure
um
how long has he work for that company
seven years have they ever been on
strike
while he worked there no sir when was
the last time they were on strike
uh 1997 I think
no you do not hunker down
okay okay now if it gets up if it gets
up closer and it heats up and it heats
up and heats up and you feel like the
probability the actual facts not the
emotions the facts of what's going on
indicate that you got a 70 or an 80
percent chance they are going to go out
then stop everything and pile up cash
but right now what you've got is a bunch
of saber rattling you know what I mean
by that
yes sir I do yeah the sounds of War but
there's not going to be War
okay
and what what I'm trying to help you do
and I have to do this myself and you
know Ken works with people on careers
and does the same thing is we have to
separate uh deloney jog Dr John deloney
talks about this anytime we're facing uh
uh an anxiety situation A trauma
situation we have to separate facts from
fears
facts are our friends what you are doing
is worrying that's what you just told me
and I do that too I do that too but when
the facts are that there's been two
meetings and there was a meltdown and
the guy stormed out and the last time
that happened there was a strike well
that's a fact we're probably going into
a strike but in the meantime what it is
it's like I don't like this they could
just put us out and we got no idea I
don't know what's going on I feel out of
control well that's just worrying
okay both are normal but we just have to
make good decisions based on all of that
okay go ahead go ahead well we have
enough in our savings account to pay off
all of our Consumer Debt Do It
um so just go ahead and do it and then
yep we'll be okay okay that makes sense
you won't have any of those payments if
you go on strike it'll be great that's
right and then Shiloh you and your
husband need to be aware because every
Union is different but the one of the
major potential strikes that's coming
down the pike is UPS right now and in
that particular this is one of the
largest the largest Union in the country
you need to find out how you worked for
a GPS okay so I actually report okay I
actually know a little bit about the
stories and wait a minute I may change
my answer so tell me what's going on
well no no actually Dave is still right
what we want to do is that has been
reported that that the union is saying
and this is posturing as well but your
husband's got to know how much am I
going to get paid during this strike and
for how long because these unions have
money set aside for strikes Dave but it
is not a per it's not forever and ever
and ever and so what you have to look at
is you have to get the numbers we could
survive I'll continue to get paid for
three months if the strike goes beyond
so these are the kind of facts that Dave
is talking about he's right we pay
attention to this and we go okay I know
that market share that UPS would lose to
FedEx in three months it'll never
recover from that's right and it'll
never happen but the point is is the
unions have enough money in a pool your
husband needs to find out yeah how long
would I get paid for and see this is the
point that Dave is making so we could
survive we pay off the debt and we
replenish that emergency fund even in a
one-month strike because I don't think
it goes longer than 30 days
these are the facts that you're talking
about Dave so you got to know yeah okay
I had no I didn't I didn't have this
other information that's all right
that's very good but yeah now I'm even
more now I'm even more sure that's right
pay off your debt work your system I'm
not saying there's never going to be a
strike I would just say there's a very
it's not going to last a long time UPS
cannot afford it no can't afford it
FedEx will eat their lunch they'll be
gone yeah
they would lose
they're you if the business aspect of
that is just mind-boggling so yeah no no
you're good you're good very good and
one other point to point out this is
like this is like Dems and Republicans
uh posturing over the debt ceiling let
me just tell you it don't matter who
they are I've been old enough I've been
around long enough to know they're going
to keep extending the debt so I don't
hear that headline oh it's going to shut
the world out no the Republicans are
going to shut the world they're going to
keep extending the debt this is
posturing and negotiation you know this
well so in this case nothing to worry
about here at all you're going to be
paid at least a month as well even the
union folks are saying we have about
three months worth of dues set aside
that would pay our members while we're
striking
so those are the nuances but actual
facts that help you make this decision
massive deal wow it is I'm going to read
on this I'm really ignorant okay fun hey
I truly don't like being ignorant so I
don't mind you being smarter than me oh
no I'm not I just have to pay attention
to work related issues like this you
know yeah Morgan's with us Morgan's in
Louisiana hi Morgan how are you
I'm great hi Dave thank you for taking
my call sure how can we help um yes sir
so I am kind of in a situation my
husband and I um we have been married
almost three years in February and
um we have our finances uh separate
um I have three children and he has one
daughter who's in college
um and so we're just trying to figure
out how to go about uh combining the
finances
um with the salary I make and his salary
and what we owe and expenses in that
nature what steps do you advisors Where
Do We Begin and so many how long ago
were you divorced
oh gosh
Mom okay and uh what was money and money
problems a contributing factor
no sir well how long ago was he divorced
uh he was uh I believe
18 to
more money problems a contributing
factor
uh yes sir yeah okay
so at some point in your new marriages
you have to be married to the person you
are married to now not the one you used
to be married to meaning he can't hold
her misbehavior with money against you
and use that as a reason to not combine
finances that's why I ask those
questions this is typically what causes
people to not combine their finances who
have been married once they got trashed
the last time
and it's hard not it's hard it's hard to
go back you know it's hard to go oh yes
I'm going to treat you know but he
really has that as a part of his healing
from that other divorce is his
commitment to you and the two of you
combining your finances so tactically
what you do is uh we change our we
change our Proverbs and Proverbs we
change our pronouns okay it's our money
not your money my money it's our income
it's our debt it's our house it's our
grocery bill there's not a yours in mine
if you don't do this you lower your
probability of Building Wealth
tremendously all of the data that we
have says that people that work together
have a much higher probability of
becoming wealthy than those who run two
separate households like a couple of
freaking roommates
absolutely Dave and and that's how we
both feel that we're we're just like you
know so you just put it in one pile you
have one pile of income at the top of
the page yours plus his equals hour and
then we have our expenses down the page
our food our lights our water our house
our our our our vacation uh we're
visiting your mother and we are paying
for that and whatever it is right that
count you got it it's all the way down
the page and if you guys are paying for
his daughter's College that's our
expense because you married her when you
married him
yes yes right am I am I off track here
you are on track and I'm gonna say I had
two
um and that fault in struggling with the
finance from the first marriage yeah so
we both have been uh you gotta forgive
the person you're married to now because
they didn't do anything wrong
it's hard though because it's human
nature to not put your hand out once a
dog it you know
ouch
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
good
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships I'm
Dave Ramsey your host Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host and we'll be
talking about your life your money and
of course your jobs and your careers
which is what Ken talks about every day
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
John starts this hour in Las Vegas hey
John how are you
hey gentlemen doing well good I just
have a quick question
um it's if I can use a signing bonus to
buy a new car
you can
the question is should you
yes that's better said okay is this a
brand new car or New To You
uh new to me potentially brand new we'll
see and what would the payments be
um I'm planning to cash flow it but my
situation to give a little more
background is I am about to start dental
school at the end of this month
however I I'm also married we have no
debt
um and I have a full scholarship for
dental school so it won't be paying out
of pocket anything for that because
you're going into the service
correct Army good
and all of this means you need to buy a
car why
so no don't need to but my wife and I
are planning to have kids in the new
near future and she's wanting a newer
car that's a more kid-friendly right now
we have a 2014 Toyota Camry nothing
super wrong nothing wrong with it it's
just I mean it's
well it has 160 000 miles on it and
while you're in dental school what will
your income be
she's a nurse and so we're currently in
Vegas but we're going to be moving to
Boston so in Boston her income will
probably be around a hundred thousand
dollars good cool and do you get any
kind of stipend while you're in from the
military while you're in Dental School
I do I get about
200 a month for 10 and a half months a
year and then it's a little bit more I
think it's closer to like 3 600 for the
other month and a half so you have a
household income of 130 000 at that
point how much was the signing bonus
20 20 grand okay all right and it will
be taxed yeah here's a couple of rules
of thumb on vehicles
all things with motors and wheels go
down in value
they are the largest thing that we buy
that goes down in value they help us
burn money more than anything else we do
we set fire to dollar bills as we buy
them and drive them me too I like cars
okay I like cars with loud mufflers not
batteries but everybody's got their own
thing right so here's the thing uh in
other words when we're not against
vehicles or something like that that's
not the point but if you you don't want
to have vehicles totaled up that's more
than half your annual income
so that would leave you at a seventy
thousand dollars or so sixty five
thousand dollars worth of vehicles we're
not doing that so you're you're not
going to be able to that I'm guessing
the other car is worth what you got two
cars
no we we uh only have one car because
we're moving to the east coast okay
we're so you're gonna be fine if you buy
one car under 65 000 on that rule you're
definitely gonna do that okay rule
number two is you pay cash
for whatever you do so whatever the
little uh little hoopty Toyota brings
plus 20 grand is what you could spend
Max
you have any other money saved
we have about
um 40ish thousand saved in about 18 in a
Roth IRA for retirement okay so you've
got a little money you got a little bit
of an emergency fund that's good news
um and you got to say 20 minus the taxes
because you don't want getting tax
trouble right so 20 minus the taxes plus
whatever the Toyota brings is what she
could buy what you can buy and here's
the last bit of advice you guys are
young how old are you
24. okay so this is old man Dave you
ready
don't buy a car for a baby that's not
even on the way yet
that's an excuse that I wanted a better
car it's okay to buy a better car just
because I want a better car and I got
the money but don't blame the baby that
isn't even on the way
it's not his fault
okay yeah and listen
here's the other thing too you can buy a
nice car and one baby doesn't need a
giant SUV one baby baby doesn't need the
nicest minivan out there maybe it's your
car seat Babies are small that car seat
will fit fine in that in that Camry yeah
they take up they take up a lot of uh a
lot of smell room but they're small yeah
right that's exactly right oh my gosh
this is a great time for you man
congratulations what a great way to go
to dental school yeah instead of being
400 000 in debt you're serving this
country thank you for serving your
country it's very well done yes sir
you're thinking about what to do with
this you're not just you didn't just
impulse and Drive by The Car Lot and go
buy some bunch of crap you can't afford
you're very thoughtful you're very wise
you guys are going to be great parents
you're going to do very well we're very
proud of you John and again thanks for
serving your country yeah very stacked a
good amount of cash too they've sown
they've shown some impulse control
already yeah so that's a good base to
but this is the natural Dave I don't
know you've been around on this people
start freaking out when you think well
we're gonna try having a baby but here's
the reality and I don't want to be a
damper on anyone but you have no control
as to when baby shows up and so stack
cash once this is why you listen to the
show getting information you would get
no other way that's genius no control
when babies come that comes straight
from Ken Coleman fresh Insight just
right off the presses well nobody knew
that hey Stacy and I struggle with
infertility for seven years I'm not
trying to be a downer the point is is
that stacking cash and then you have
time to buy the nice car the nicer car
and I just think I want young couples to
look at the Long View because it never
hurts by the way as soon as you adopted
you got pregnant let's just keep that in
mind that's true that's just that's the
magic thing right there yeah well that
comes with its own expenses so there you
go careful on that one but yeah you get
the point is that we we jump to
conclusions because the emotion the
excitement oh it's exciting it is
natural for people to do this and you're
looking at the crappy car going I hate
this car and so our little precious
little baby needs a nice car
not wait till they spit up all over it
you know the first time that new carpet
gets all stinky well the worst ones were
the toddlers oh they can just they could
turn a car into a circular waste Zone
yeah and by the way it is my opinion
that goldfish they re they reproduce
when the kids drop them on the floor of
the car they reproduce there's like 10
more every time you get in the
caring one segment we get that babies
can't be planned yeah and and goldfish
reproduce we get one segment we get this
gold from you hey Common Sense can
that's what you can call me just
dropping the dropping the depth today
drop
ladies and gentlemen watch out he's
everywhere don't let the common sense
sneak up on you check out the podcast
oh you gotta love it open phones here at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and um
by the way uh we'll just go ahead and
add one little extra serious note to
that if you have a car that's worth
eight thousand dollars that won't hold
the car seats because you got now
another car seat or something go buy
something that's worth eight thousand
dollars
not twenty eight thousand that'll hold
the car seats they make eight thousand
dollar used vans too
you can move laterally you don't have to
move up 20 grand just to get bigger see
that's where we know you're
rationalizing this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
back to the Ramsey Show I'm your host
Dave Ramsey Ken Coleman is my co-host
today number one best-selling author
host of the Ken Coleman show now we hang
out in Nashville in case you guys forgot
and there's always these famous music
people dropped by and see us that's not
happening today instead an extremely
famous comedian from Nashville is
dropping by our friend Nate bargatzi hey
Nate how are you good how are y'all
doing great man hey the Amazon special
rocked uh thank you yeah it was great I
uh it's very exciting to be here Dave
we've you know listened to you obviously
my whole life uh with because my parents
would tell me to do stuff that you tell
people to do never I didn't I wasn't
great at it but they had all the ideas
but I I kind of told you at this party I
also moved you when I was like 20 oh it
had been 20 years ago uh you're in a
house I think going to a lake house yeah
and yeah
house down Lester Springs and I uh so we
were moving you like the company I
worked for we went to your house and
moved you and my one thing you were very
nice everything's great I remember you
had a TV this was back when TVs were big
yeah they take two guys to carry one of
those yeah but this TV I don't remember
it wasn't it was like I think what I
remember is like a it wasn't in like a
you know if you had a big wide screen if
it was a smaller one but then you go hey
that TV is pretty heavy and you know I'm
20 you know I'm like I got it Dave don't
worry like this is this is what I do as
I move TVs and I picked it up and if you
kept concreting that TV I would believe
that it was the heaviest TV I've ever
felt in my life and then me and my buddy
both had a carrot and I remember not
being so big because our faces were
super close to each other because we
were just like walking like one side on
the other side but I always think about
that TV
I'm so glad that Dave Ramsey made an
impression Pizza
my big ones he goes that TV's heavy you
might need some help and I go I got it
Dave don't worry about it don't worry
about me and then you're like oh this is
the heaviest TV I've ever felt in my
life so the uh changing gears the Amazon
special we watched it the other night it
is excellent you did an amazing job
um the uh the The Experience had to be
so much better than the one the the
thing you did during covet that that was
like a root canal wasn't it oh yeah just
outside everybody mask on I couldn't
hear him laugh the first uh so when you
do shows uh if you you say you're gonna
do an hour you know of material or
whatever uh that can also depend on the
crowd if it's gonna be an hour like so
if the crowd if you can't really hear
them laugh and you're having to talk
faster it's like that hour becomes 40
minutes 45 like that much and if the
crowd's Laughing great that hour can be
an hour and 15 minutes and uh the first
when we did the covered one uh I got
done taping and it was at like I want to
say 43 minutes or something and they
were like right when I got off they were
like yeah we do not have it because you
taped two shows when you tape a special
and then you add it on to get like use
it and usually it's all from one show
but then you have maybe a couple jokes
you said better and so when I got done
uh they were like yeah we that was so
short and I was like well I can't hear
anybody laughing you can't tell they had
mask on so you can't even see their face
if they're well joy role of the audience
was just horrendous oh I mean it was
painful yeah it was painful I mean as
somebody who's also on stage obviously
not a comedian but also does a lot of
speaking and stuff it was painful to
think about what you're experiencing but
this one this one and the the setup the
production values on this latest one the
the way the audience was coming around
you and the way you were working them
yeah it was really good well I wanted to
after like uh this place where I taped
this one uh the celebrity theater in
Phoenix it's uh one of my favorite
venues uh Carlin taped a special there
Louis CK taped a special there and uh
it's it was such a cool like you could
see the red car and especially you could
see the crowd a lot because it was just
back it was like 70 something when he
taped it and so it's just that's how it
was but I wanted to show a crowd I
wanted to show people having fun because
after covet and all that stuff and say I
wanted it was like you just wanted the
crowd to see like look it's all
everybody people are having fun and
people are back out and people are doing
that stuff so it's like we kind of lit
up the crowd a little bit so you could
see them and uh yeah it's that place is
the best as a pastor's kid when you
started talking about the words that you
were allowed to say and not allowed to
say it was absolutely hilarious I've got
to ask you this this is a money show uh
we know that a lot of money issues in
marriage yeah so I'm just curious your
own marriage your wife's role with money
your role with money like what's that
like for you it's I have no role in it
so it's her
uh I don't know I mean I used to have
jokes like I was like if my wife ever
died like I would like I don't know what
bank I would go to like well I don't
know how to get my money out I'd have to
call her mom and ask her to be like you
know what is your maiden name uh uh I
wouldn't know I mean it's I'm
disconnected you know when you grow up
we didn't have money like and so even
though I know is the pressure on my
parents for raising us and saving money
and doing all that stuff I was just
fortunately I guess kind of oblivious I
never really thought about it and I kind
of went in that with comedy and so money
like I've just never
uh thought about it so much it's just
kind of like you're doing what you're
doing like in comedy I would always have
little check marks where I could realize
uh you know I worked at Applebee's I met
my wife at Applebee's on Thompson Lane
and we were yep we worked there together
and so our flare yeah the flare yeah
yeah all the Flair so I remember in
comedy when I got to the point where I
was making just as much as I'd be making
at Applebee's and someone didn't go to
college or anything I was like all right
like I'm making as much as I would make
as you know thirty thousand dollars a
year whatever it is and then you slowly
just have little check marks where you
can just be like all right I'm making
this like I wouldn't make more than this
at whatever job I have uh so but my wife
is the one that does all of it how's it
feel when someone says Grammy nominated
it's crazy that's that's one that you
never I mean because you're like why
would I have to get any of this stuff
like you know as you say uh better than
I deserve uh it's you you don't think I
don't deserve any of this stuff and so
it's and being just from here in Old
Hickory and uh you know who am I like
I'm nobody so it's it's all wild and
it's hard to like take in but it's stuff
I did want you know I have you have your
goal you want to yeah when you think
about it you do want to be as big as you
can be but it's uh yeah when it happens
it's it's pretty surreal how many years
were you at the trade before things
really started to move for you uh I've
done I've done it 20 years and uh so I
was at it I mean you know it's all
gradually I always say you either make
it at 20 or 40 and no one makes it in
the middle so you either get lucky and
get plucked or you have to go grind it
out and uh so it was all kind of
gradually always just kind of moving up
and uh I would say after the Netflix
special the Tennessee kid the stand-ups
in the Tennessee kid was when it really
kind of we took a pretty big leap to
where you go to theaters and people are
there to see you like they know you know
you gotta have new material really you
gotta have all this stuff like they're
there to absolutely see you but I'm not
still getting Amazed by it every day I
was just at the American Century golf
tournament and like just the autographs
and the fact that people know who you
are and you're you know just taking all
these pictures I mean it's it's pretty
are you on the course when Steph hit the
hole in one I was two holes over so you
heard it it was yeah and so we didn't
know who did it but the the roar was so
loud that you're like all right well
someone hey you're like someone's got
that has to be a whole one and then it's
so loud and long then you're like well I
don't know who it is and then they
someone radios over like one of the
volunteers and they're like it was Steph
Curry and you're like well I mean that's
that couldn't have worked out better for
uh NBC and all that it was a very cool
thing to see and to hear it just the
roar yeah wow Nate margacci on
grammy-nominated comedian a neighbor of
ours here in Nashville dropping by to
hang out be sure and check out his new
special on Amazon on hello world and of
course she's on tour right now and how
many cities you're doing uh it's uh all
of them I think uh we go I'm leaving
Australia Saturday this Saturday oh that
would be in Australia yeah yeah you've
never been out there doing it doing it
with um doing the show with a little jet
lag oh yeah I think we have a couple
days you lose two days when you go out
there I don't know never knew tickets at
nateburgazi.com yep yep there you go and
social at Nate yeah thanks for dropping
by man congratulations on all your
success couldn't happen to a better guy
uh honor man honor to be here we always
loved you and uh so it's very cool to be
here we're honored hey Nate bargason
check it out this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their one
action guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Aaron is with us
in Colorado Springs hey Aaron welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thank you sure what's up
so my husband and I are on baby steps
four five and six and I feel like we've
been doing the Ramsey plan forever and
I'm we're both ready to be done with the
mortgage so we've been trying to come up
with ways to pay it off and it just
seems like it's gonna take longer we
want to be done in three years by the
time we turn 40 and how long is forever
that you've been working on this
well we've been doing it about 15 years
but five of those we were overseas so
you know we kind of had to stop
um we bought a house we sold that we
moved overseas and while we were
overseas our housing was paid so we
saved up money so we moved back right in
2020 and the housing prices had gone
crazy and the money we saved we thought
we could pay cash for a house we ended
up having to take out a mortgage
and now we're we've got 120 000 left and
what's your household income
120. okay and you're gonna be done in
three years and you're how old
we want to be done in three years we're
36. okay and before you're 40. okay I
get it okay so what's the question then
so we've run the numbers and we've
already been putting about 50 of our
take-home pay towards the house
um but with all the other baby steps and
just life
um you know we still need about 20 grand
more a year to be able to reach that
goal and so
we've talked about either stopping doing
fun things which I know isn't what is
meant to happen in baby step four five
and six or my husband has to take a
second job or I work more and all of
those options are just they're hard and
so we thought well do we change the goal
I mean how intense do we need to be in
this step because for me I want to be
done tomorrow but I also understand for
three years we shouldn't be you know
running like gazelle intense so how do
you balance that
so twenty thousand dollars more per year
that's the number that gets it done in
three years in three years yeah so why
does it have to be so incredibly hard
it's not necessary you guys are doing
great but if you really break it down to
how do we the Two of Us come up with an
additional twenty thousand dollars a
year without making life absolutely too
difficult there you know what I'm saying
and I think that's what you got to
figure out it doesn't require such a
drastic choice and it feels like the way
you're setting it up to us it feels
really big and heavy and I'm not sure it
needs to be big and heavy I think it's a
good goal to go for but it could also be
managed twenty thousand dollars not that
much all of your projections assume no
raises too
yeah but the raises haven't been you
know the projection for that isn't
fabulous wow so
um just because of the the my husband
works in a Ministry so you know over
time the raises haven't been great I
mean they're good they pay good and it's
a great job but yeah and what do you
think more you know I I homeschool my
kids and stay home I do a little side
work making a couple
here and we've talked about me working
more but you know our Focus right now is
our kids and the home needs to be
peaceful environment and that allows my
husband to do his work and if I'm busy
and stressed then that just kind of I
think breaks down a lot of that so
um I feel like my time is maxed out
really at this point
okay I I would without the level of
pressure that you're putting on yourself
I would move from uh I would not move to
intense I would stay at intentional and
I would dial back the pressure these are
really good goals
they are not worth or not that's not the
right word
you can be intentional and get there
almost as fast as you get there if you
worry and fret and ring your hands over
it so um if you don't get there in three
years and it takes four oh well you're
still very weird in such a good way
you've done such a great job you'll be
41 with a paid for house for goodness
sakes and your husband's in Ministry oh
my goodness how wonderful are you guys
so give yourself a little Grace hey
there's a word and
um you know just get give yourself a
little bit of breathing room here and
then
and just make it a game and it's a
Monopoly game and we want to lean into
it but the the level of pressure that I
hear in your voice I I don't want that
for you
or for your husband I want you guys to
just enjoy your run and just enjoy this
ride
I'm done am I done knowing people money
I want all our money coming in uh you
know what I completely agree with you
and so um I'd make it a matter of prayer
God send us some extra money because we
want to be done with this we don't want
any Masters in our life but you and just
begin to pray that each morning and and
then you know with that prayer let's
look at what we can do I mean can you
pick up a little tutoring is there a
thing over here you guys can turn down a
little bit and Ken's right you might
find the other 20 000 as you go along
here and then even then if you're 41 and
you're debt free you are so far ahead of
the game in America today you're so far
over in the smart column when we look up
y's in the dictionary we're going to see
your picture oh my gosh you're doing
great breathe a little uh I'm with you
I'm done owing money I'm never going
back and I can get fired up about that I
can get wired up about that and there's
no chance I'm going to do it and if I
were in your shoes I'd want be out just
as bad as you want to be out but not
enough to completely destroy our life
for the next three years gazelle
intensity of that level is necessary
when you're in baby step two it is not
what you should be doing in baby steps
four five and six
you should be intentional not intense
and there is a difference intentional is
I'm an adult and I make every dollar
behave I'm not an immature child
throwing a fit and says I deserve it
because I work so hard you're not having
any of those stupid conversations and
you're not that person you're doing good
I think you're doing good you're doing
so much better than you feel like you're
doing we think you're better than you
think you are yeah I think that's right
Dave and I love the intentional here
because listen she's homeschooling
multiple kids that three years is going
to go by pretty quick so enjoy the
season that you're in be blessed because
you've done the hard work to be in this
moment Joshua's in Dallas hey Joshua
what's up
okay Dave a quick question for you I am
almost done with baby step three and
then just got divorced or I have a
second mortgage on this house and I'm
trying to figure out am I treating it
like the first one and sticking to step
three or do I treat it like death and
I'm technically back to step two if it's
under half your annual income it's a
baby step two
let's see how much do you owe how much
do you owe on the second
uh 50 uh 45 and what's your household
what's your income
about 81
. it's right on the bubble okay I would
throw it to baby step six and uh what's
your interest rate on your first
mortgage
uh it's only like
3.125 yeah
well make sure you've got really good
terms on this and let's get it you know
I yeah
it's only a 10-year yeah
I don't want you being in debt on either
one of them for 10 years I want to go
and clear them right but um exactly but
but the
yeah you don't have anything else to do
you might as well just get in and lean
in on it but you don't have to lean in
again lean in on it with intentionality
if when you're paying extra on a
mortgage right now it's on that it's not
the first
right and so any money you scrape
together in your budget Beyond 15 going
into retirement after baby in baby steps
four is it baby step six is going to go
on the mortgage and in your situation
today
um
you you know you you're probably uh you
just have to manage you now right
exactly yeah so I mean
in that sense your expenses went down or
or can if you choose for them to you
don't have to convince anybody to do
this but you
and so whatever you choose to do however
fast you want to clear that so it's
going to end up other than the fact
you're putting money into retirement
it's going to end up having the same
effect as almost as being in baby step
two if I'm in your shoes I'm just going
to attack it but go at it at whatever
speed you want there but I'm going to
put it at baby step six it's over half
your annual income
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Deborah is with us in Los Angeles hi
Deborah welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks so much I've been listening to
you guys for years and appreciate all
you do oh thank you um I have you're
very welcome I have a question for you
I've been listening for a long time and
yesterday I went into
um to adjust my own Investments because
I am we've been focused on other things
I wanted to get everything set up in the
four different types of mutual funds you
mentioned and the guy who is not a not a
Ramsey and Certified Financial Pro but
he um he mentioned a term that I'd never
heard before when I brought up mutual
funds he asked me if I'd considered ETFs
and I have no idea or I hadn't heard
what that was he explained it to me and
it sounds very similar to mutual friend
so I was just wondering if you could
clarify what the difference is and why a
mutual fund is better than an ETF
I don't know their mutual fund is better
than an ATF ETF just means extreme
exchange traded fund and for purposes
you would use it for uh they're very
very similar they're almost identical uh
it's a group of um
you know a group of stocks and if you're
buying an exchange you know typically
what people will do for an ETF is
something like an index fund like an S P
500 and so it'd just be a group of
stocks in there now sometimes uh Brokers
will try to get you to buy and sell in
your portfolio a lot and they like an
exchange traded fund for that better
um and so if you're setting it up to do
like you set up a brokerage account to
buy and sell stocks in I would not use
it for that but if you're using it like
a mutual fund just to buy and hold
you're going to find it's almost
identical that you didn't really you're
not going to notice any difference in
the Practical use of it
so uh sometimes I hear things like well
Dave Ramsey's against ETFs I'm not
against ETFs I don't mind what I want
you to have is a diversified portfolio
mutual funds ETF is either one of those
that give it to you what I don't want
you to do with an ETF is start buying
and selling all the time and I don't
want you to use any vehicle of investing
that that prompts you to constantly be
jumping in and out jumping in and out
jumping in and out because every time
the the you know the the news is good by
the time the news is good on the stock
market you're late
you should have already been in by the
time the news is bad it's already too
late for you to get out and so people
that try to jump in and out based on the
news and you're not saying that Deborah
I'm just saying but in general if you're
trying to use an ETF to time the market
we call it then then that use is not
something that you know that we would
tell people to do ever because I don't
time the market I just buy and hold
I'll never sell it let's buy and keep it
and uh well the stock market went down
yeah I know stock market went up yeah I
know
and if I just sit there uh then I'm fine
and so but but for your purposes Deborah
I think he's fine as long as you're
gonna stick with it and as long as he's
not your your planner is not
recommending the ETF for purposes of
timing the market or buying and selling
or constantly trading on your funds I
don't be trading on my funds all the
time I buy them and hold them the only
time I sell a fund
is if uh it's just completely
underperformance category over a long
period of time and I don't remember the
last time I sold one it's been a long
long time because I just I play long
ball all the time play long ball I'm
always thinking what's this going to be
10 years from now what's it going to be
20 years from now not 10 days from now
not 10 months from now the emotions
don't drive it and again Deborah you're
not being accused of any of that but I'm
trying to couch my ETF answer here so I
don't get misunderstood again because
I'm not anti-etf I'm anti-timing and I'm
anti-constantly trading because it's
effectively gambling if you try to play
the market you can really get no longer
invest in you're speculating that's
correct yeah and and you are you know
from a statistical standpoint not a
spiritual standpoint you are gambling
right you know and so uh and sometimes I
hear people say in the crew in the
Christian world that I'm in you know
they'll say stuff like well all stock
market isn't is gambling and you
shouldn't be doing that well you don't
understand what gambling is
gambling is not based on gambling is
based on a it's a game of chance right
meaning you don't have any control or
any insight that's right over the over
the output that's right investing as you
buy a piece of real estate why because
real estate's always gone up and real
estate in that neighborhood is a great
neighborhood it's got nice trees and
it's going to be good and whatever you
know and or if you're in Arizona nice
cactuses or what I mean whatever it is
right and so you know we're gonna but we
have actual outputs that we're measuring
and and we can look at the probabilities
and it's not just a deck of cards
it's not a slot machine there's a
complete difference and there's a
difference in the spirit by which you go
at those things so none of that has to
do with Deborah but but Deborah thanks
for the question Jessica's with us in
Madison Wisconsin hi Jessica welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi thanks for having me on great how can
we help
oh my question is I had received some
money when my dad passed away we use
that money to pay off uh vehicles and
use it as a down payment on our house
and all we had for debt then was a
mortgage since then we've bought a
tractor and built a barn we were told to
just let the money ride in the market we
were never going to touch it that was
that was retirement money as I've been
listening to your show the last couple
weeks I'm wondering if that was the best
advice we were given and if we should
pull the money from you know the stocks
and pay off our debt and then yeah and
then you need to quit buying crap you
can't afford like Barns and tractors
uh it's stuff needed for our mobile
you're buying stuff you can't afford
okay you know how I know you did that
you borrowed on it instead of paying for
it
if it was such a dadgum good investment
you would have already used Eddie's
stock money on that
hello
yep I'm here yeah my my question is do
we pull the money from the stocks and no
you don't unless you're going to quit
borrowing money and on the next thing
that you'd rationalize and justify
but if you're stop rationalizing and
justifying your purchases on debt
because you're going to eventually run
out of this if you keep this Behavior
pattern going
but if you stop the behavior pattern and
say I'm never borrowing again we're
going to pay cash for everything we do
from this point forward then yes we did
this but the last time you paid off all
your debts what'd you do the next time
thing that came up you went back in debt
and so if I tell you to pay off this
debt next thing that comes up you're
going to go back in debt I don't want
that for you that's not a that's not a
method to Prosperity that's a method to
bankruptcy
and so you've got to put your you know
you gotta spit shake and uh pinky swear
with your husband we we're not borrowing
money anymore if you're going to do that
then yeah I'll take the money out and
pay off the debt but otherwise you're
destined to live a life of put and take
we're going to pay it off then we're
gonna go back in debt we're gonna pay it
off and we're gonna go back in debt and
eventually we don't have any money to
pay it off eventually you run out of the
nest egg doing that so you've got to
break this pattern and you were very
clear we used some of the money cleared
off all the debt wait how did we
celebrate we bought a tractor and a barn
and went back in debt you've got to
break that cycle you can't do that again
and again and again there's an end to it
and the end ain't pretty so that's what
I want for you and there's no
rationalization no justification you got
to be done you'll be done you got to
decide we're done you know it's an
investment it's always an investment
everybody says everything's an
investment that they want to buy but
most things aren't yeah and this is a
key point about behaviors aren't
Investments or the barn so what happens
is when you feel the need to have
something you have to go okay what's the
least amount of thing that I need to do
what I want to do could we have done a
shed that we could have paid cash for
what's Behind These purchases not
prospective opportunities I'm going to
need this Barn one day if we don't need
the bar now then we don't need to buy
the bar now and I think that's where
people have got to start looking at this
and going away what do I really need do
I need a big tractor do I need an old
used tractor that'll do the job and
that's what people have to do or else
you justify debt almost every one of us
buy a different thing when we buy it
with debt than if we bought it with cash
I agree with that 100 almost every one
of us yeah and you buy a bigger badder
cooler that's correct crazier yeah
nuttier yeah Dumber right thing you got
to find a way because it doesn't feel
like it's real money when it's the
bank's money that's absolutely right and
that's the that's the Trap of this it's
a it's a siren song yeah and you know
you'll crash this puppy on the rocks and
that's what the sirens do to you look it
up this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality host of the Ken Coleman show
number one best-selling author on the
subjects of work job and career we're
here to answer your questions about life
and money open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Ken
will be my co-host for the day Irene is
in McAllen Texas starting this hour hi
Irene how are you
hi I'm doing really good how are you
guys better than we deserve what's up
so my main question is should I should I
sell my rental property we became as you
all call it a landlords by default and
I'm not sure we should sell it where we
are right now we're in baby step two
um with about five thousand dollars to
go on our credit card
um and we do also have a car loan that
we're paying off with our LLC so I don't
know I'm sure that's also part of um
baby step two
doesn't matter your LLC is not liable
you are no matter how you're paying it
you signed the no personally it's
personal debt so it is baby step two so
what do you owe on the rental
it's paid off
okay what's it worth
it would go for about 160 to 170 right
now cool and uh your personal residence
is it paid off
it's not paid off we bought it two years
ago we still owe about 183.
[Music]
and what's your household income
uh 75 000. okay
I would rather have a paid off house
than a paid off rental
my personal home
yeah yep I agree
so my
I guess is
we've never really been goes out in tens
and I I'm feeling kind of like using
this rental property uh would kind of be
like an easy way out
um we did just start following the baby
steps since January and we've been able
to pay off 13 000 in debt
um since then so we are you know going
through the baby steps but I just I'm
feeling a little bit weird about kind of
uh I don't know I feel like I'm cheating
by using that rental property
well you're not cheating if you've
changed your habits permanently if
you're not if you cheat if you pay off
all this stuff and then you maintain the
go back to the same stupid habits you
used to do then yeah that was cheating
and it didn't have the positive effect
right but there's nothing that there's
no data that says getting out of debt
easy is a bad way to get out of debt
okay I just wonder if that's a really
logical excuse for holding on to the
rental
um not really I'm really not in love
with this rental
um it's in a great location but it's a
little older and it's kind of become you
know not so passive we're constantly
having to fix things and go out there so
you know I'm not attached to it then I
would sell it and get over the guilt of
fast forward but here's the thing you
know the two of you have to look at each
other and say if we're going to do this
then we've got to do the whole thing not
just to sell the rental and get out of
that thing we've got to live on a budget
we have to live on less than we make we
save up and pay for things from this
point forward we keep an emergency fund
we're going to pay off finish paying off
to our house as soon as possible because
this doesn't quite by the time you clear
the car and the credit card you don't
have enough to clear the house
and and so you're gonna have to lean in
and get the house paid off as soon as
possible it's not going to be paid for
so you're not done you've got to play
all the way through and if you're but
you can't commit to just doing parts of
what we are telling you to do or parts
of what we teach around here that could
actually be harmful to you not really
but it it just it's ineffective and then
you say stuff like well that Dave Ramsey
stuff doesn't work and that's not true
you just didn't do it right so it does
work if you do it so you gotta do the
whole thing though you can't pick and
choose it's not all a cart we're not at
a buffet line you do the whole puppy
this is Chef's tasting menu you get
every course all the way through that
that if you do that Amanda I mean uh
Irene you're going to be just fine
Amanda is who we're talking to next
she's in Lexington hi Amanda how are you
I'm good thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so um I recently got remarried and me
and my new husband we are doing the
Financial Peace University and we're on
baby step two
um I was in a previous marriage before
and I have a 12 year old son from my
previous marriage and his father we
never paid child support but he actually
passed away about a year and a half ago
oh wow and he draws Social Security
money from him from his deceased father
right
um so before I got married I was a
single mom and I had saved like 6 000 of
it which I ended up spending 4 000 of it
for braces this week for my son so he's
got 2 000 left in the savings account
and then he gets 900 a month so my
question is
should I invest that for my son put it
towards a bit snowball or I'm just not
sure what would be the smartest way
because I haven't really been smart with
my money but being my new husband like
we're on track to we're on your plan so
we want to make sure we're doing
everything we're supposed to do good
okay well let's be uh clear I've raised
three kids and you're obviously doing
raising kids
um You Can't Raise a kid
for 900 bucks a month
it costs more it costs more than that
and the whole scope of their life it
costs more than that and this money
morally not legally but morally should
be used for the care of the child if
you're taking care of the child you're
spending more than that
so if you blend all the money in with
your whole budget as long as you take
care of the kid and all of his needs and
expenses then you've done nothing wrong
I would I would blend it into your
budget
right now with you know go ahead and do
that or wait till we get to that baby
step how do I get to that baby step and
I would blend this money into your
budget
again this money it does there is no
moral or legal reason to separate this
money off and set it aside for him while
you owe on the uh you know you set 900
aside over here and you spend 1400 over
here
and that you know that that didn't
accomplish anything and so you're going
to take care of your child if you're
going to take care of your child and
you're not you know using his money to
snort cocaine or something then you know
as long as you take care of your child
that's the point
and it's going to cost you more than you
get in child support or in Social
Security payments and so we always blend
child support and we always blend Social
Security payments into the budget it's
part of the household income and then
the household is under the
responsibility morally ethically
spiritually to take care of the child
and that includes someday they go to
college and that's going to be a great
expense to you much greater expense than
the money the government gave you
including raising him including putting
braces and so on so I just make it all
in one pile us and I'm assuming when we
do that that you're a great mom and
you're going to take care of your baby
and as long as you're doing that then
that's a great piece of advice and
that's what I would do good question
thank you for joining us this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
all
[Music]
right
foreign
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the Ramsey Show question
of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
neighborly is the place to find Reliable
help for your home from trusted locally
owned businesses like Glassdoor
Precision garage door service and Mr
Handyman visit neighborly.com great
company today to find some home experts
available to serve you today's question
comes from Brad in Idaho why are
teachers consistently in the group of
people that become millionaires I'll
just I'm going to add to this question
he's referring to the Ramsey Solutions
study the largest group of millionaires
ever done over ten thousand and they
were in the top five School teachers of
net worth millionaires is what he's
referring to he goes on to say is it
because they marry well and have a
spouse with a better income or is there
another reason are there other career
Fields I should look into that
consistently make it into the
millionaire club uh you know I can't
wait for Dave's take on this I'll tell
you one thing that I believe is
absolutely a reason that teachers are in
that group is because they are missional
they care deeply about their role we
also found in that same study that 96 96
of net worth millionaires love their
work and in the teacher case they're
very dedicated to be instructors they
care deeply about serving kids and
they've chosen work that is Meaningful
to them and thus they've decided that
what they make is enough and they've
made the choices to live on less than
they make and choose a lifestyle that
actually supports their work not the
other way around and I think it's about
deep meaning and purpose and thus
they've been disciplined and they're
very methodical and I think that's a
part that plays too Dave what would you
add to that or do you does that square
with you I think that's you know when we
got the data in it was interesting to us
um you know the the top five
career fields of the millionaires in the
largest study of millionaires ever done
in North America number one was engineer
number two is accountant number three
was teacher number four was business
professional which can mean almost
anything
um and number five was um lawyer
a medical doctor didn't even make the
top five the number six and they are
stereotypically worse with money than
music artists I mean it's ridiculous and
so
um not all in other words not all of
them but I'm saying The Stereotype is is
there for a reason so
what we figured out is is that okay why
is it why do these five land there and
and even if we look at further down the
list why do some of these top what what
is what do they have in common and what
it does disprove is that your income
causes you to become a millionaire
because one third of the millionaires
that we studied 33 percent of them never
made over a hundred thousand dollars
so it's not your income
in other words you can't earn your way
out of stupidity
so what did those what is an engineer an
accountant a lawyer a business
professional teacher have in common and
I think you hit it on the head when you
said method they are they are systems
people they work with a set of
principles and they don't
um
they don't they don't have free reign to
make up their own rules there's when
you're a lawyer and you go before the
judge you have to follow exact
procedures
even exact ways of addressing the court
if it pleases the court your honor you
don't talk to humans out in the at the
gas station that way it's a set of
procedures that you use there's a proper
set of emotions that and you don't have
a choice you don't get to you know well
I'm creative you're you know old man in
the robe you don't get to say that okay
you get to say if it pleases the court
your honor I mean you don't have a
choice in this you don't have a choice
when you're an engineer designing a
bridge there's basically one way
otherwise it falls yep you know and
accountants don't say uh well this is
creative they call that embezzlement you
know I mean it's like right and so
accounting is a set of generally
accepted accounting principles Gap and
the process of doing counting there's
one process and you submit yourself to
proven principles and methods to be
successful in any of those careers and
money works exactly the same way right
you have to submit commit yourself to a
set of proven principles you live on
less than you make you're generous you
invest you have a written plan you're in
agreement with your spouse these are set
principles that you don't get to be
created well in my I don't think it
works yeah yeah I don't agree who gives
a crap if you agree this is the way the
bridge is built yeah this is the way
that you do a lesson plan if you're a
teacher right this is the proper
methodology for instructing it is so
structured and so they're used to
functioning in in a structured
environment and submitting themselves to
proven structured processes which money
and wealth building are and that's what
the correlation was it took us a little
while to figure it out and let's also
understand that they have to be
intentional to win with their income
because they can't they can't rely on
big increases in income
one-third of the millionaire has never
made over a hundred thousand let me keep
that in mind and here's but Brad let me
address one other thing are there other
career Fields I should look into that
consistently make it to the millionaire
Club no that's right do not pick your
field because you think it's going to
make you rich yeah let's never do that
but are there processes that you can
submit yourself to yes that will get you
into the millionaire Club absolutely
there are but you don't pick your career
field because what you'll be is a
miserable human being with a big income
if you pick the you know I'm doing this
just for the money money wears off man
you eat enough Lobster tastes like soap
so true there's just not there's only so
much money so much money will do and so
you you know you don't pick your no you
know it's like you don't pick your wife
based on the net worth of her father you
know that's a bad way of doing it you
know it's good you're going to get
yourself in a mess you know you know
that won't turn out well no it's going
to go poorly so yeah you you know you
pick your career field based on
purpose and meaning and can you actually
do it you know and so what you've got is
again with teachers or any accountant
they enjoy process accountants enjoy
process and they're talented at it
teachers enjoy instruction they're good
at it that's the mix and then you choose
to make your money work that's what I
love by the way in case you said we got
a lot of new people joining all the time
we love this we're here we're growing
like crazy all over the place podcast
YouTube everywhere here's the thing the
median salary right now for teachers in
the United States is about 61 000 so you
need to understand net worth of
millionaires at that level it can be
done and there's this generation that's
watching too many Tick Tock videos and
Instagram videos Dave where it says
you've got to make millions of dollars a
year uh to be wealthy and it's just
simply not true you can't out earn your
stupidity that's a fact I've tried it
didn't work you just gotta not be stupid
yeah and so you can't make enough money
to be stupid it won't work you'll lose
it I know I did it I did it I did the
zeros on the end I know what it looks
like I know exactly how it feels I know
whatever every bit of that experience no
thank you I don't want to do it again so
um you know this is what you need to
dial in on do something that you love
and find a way to do it in an unusual
way yes okay yes it doesn't necessarily
if you're a teacher it doesn't
necessarily mean you're a classroom
teacher there's a lot of ways to be a
teacher and a lot of things you can do I
have a I have a gift of teaching yeah
absolutely and so I'm a teacher if you
teach financial principles in a lot of
ways yeah and I've done it on 60 Minutes
and you've done it in 600 000 600
stations for years and then you've done
it in front of hundreds of thousands of
people and that's a very good point you
know if I love instructing I'm not
limited to a public school classroom but
that is also a wonderful place to do it
yeah
but it's not the only definition of a
teacher that's correct so um now again
the purposes of that study these were
probably classroom teachers yeah yeah
that's what we talk a lot about sure
yeah but the uh I mean I don't think
someone identifies in a survey of
millionaires that they are a teacher if
they're on the radio that's probably not
what they're that's probably not what
they're doing right so
um that's not the plan so that's a
really good question don't pick your
career
based on how much money you can make
only it should be a consideration but
um but but don't pick it based on that
only and go oh I'm going to make a lot
of money and that'll make me happy while
I'm doing stuff every day that I hate
doing yeah no that won't work
but also don't pick a career that says
oh this is going to make me happy and
it's okay if I'm broke that's not
necessarily either no you should make
more money if you're doing something you
love
because you're good at it
because you care about it because you're
creative because you've got energy you
should make more money not less yeah so
that's the way to get at it good
question thank you for joining us this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt free stage Apollo and
Elizabeth are with us hey guys how are
you good we didn't know we'd be
following a Nate bragazi so uh a little
intimidated now you never know around
here brother hey good to have you thanks
for coming by so where do you guys live
Toronto Canada oh it's a bit of a trip
to Nashville well good to have you and
how much debt have you paid off
624 thousand dollars
I love it and how long did this take 38
months whoa and your range of income
during this time it ranged between 290
000 to 310.
okay wow what do you guys do for a
living I'm in commercial real estate
leasing and I work for the government of
Canada I'm also a gemologist so during
the pandemic I opened up an online Etsy
store where I sold vintage and antique
jewelry oh my side hustle yeah wow nice
side hustle very good so what kind of
debt was a 624 000. 420 of it was our
primary home and 240 uh 204 000 of it
was a piece of investment real estate we
had ah two pieces of real estate so uh
you're all the way in Toronto Canada how
in the world do you find out about this
Ramsay stuff and how do you uh make the
decision uh touch over three years ago
you're going to go wild and knock all of
this out I've
when it comes to the budget
one day he comes home and he said have
you ever heard of this Dave Ramsey guy
and he said that he's an American from
Tennessee and he really gives it to
straight to his callers in terms of
financial advice so I checked out you
YouTube I checked out the podcast and
then I realized we weren't doing
everything that we could to become
millionaires so one of the things that
you had always said is
um get onto an everyday or every dollar
budget because that's one of the primary
ways of of becoming on the same page so
I approached him and I asked him hey
let's let's do this let's do the advice
that that Dave Ramsey gives ahead
supporting YouTube videos just in case
you had any questions and he was on
board right away so she was a little
nervous that I'd say no well you're
brought up the idea though I know I know
but I mean she asked and uh you know one
of the things I want to put out there
for all the couples that are always
saying you know about you know combining
finances she was worried about asking me
and the minute she asked me I said well
sure why not and I think that should be
everybody's reflexes if you give it at
least three six months you'll see the
results yes they'll be budget fights at
the beginning but eventually the proof
is there and what's the worst case
scenario you can go back to the way
you're doing things if it was so good
so I gotta know I want you to break this
down for our audience because you're
making between 290 and 310 you're paying
roughly 200 000 of debt per year if I'm
reading this right so how did you do
that we were doing about a hundred
thousand dollars a year of paying off
debt what happened towards the end is we
sold off the investment property so I
owned half of it with my sister and my
family's back home in Montreal which is
about 300 miles away and you know Dave
brings up the concept of one if it's too
far and two the whole concept about
owning real estate with family
and you we had the conversation I said
you know what we haven't had any of the
problems that we hear some of your call
uh your callers call in with you know
owning a rental real estate with uh with
family and it we wouldn't do it again
because you know it was so far away so
we said you know what I think it's time
to sell it and uh so that just turbo
charged our way to the end oh yeah we
blew it up yeah very cool so you you
brought the idea to her have you ever
heard of this Dave Ramsey got where did
you hear about him so I found you on
YouTube okay same thing and I love the
southern twang I have to admit yeah and
uh it's my greatest attribute I know
it's nothing to do with intelligence
wisdom anything else it's just the twang
the twang sells you yeah good for you
man I'm thank you guys thank you so much
I'm so proud of you how's it feel to be
a hundred percent free with this huge
income it's amazing it's absolutely
liberating you know Dave uh you use the
the visual of chains
to the debt and when you say you know
how does it feel I think that is the
proper visual to give people during your
teachings because you really feel
Unshackled from it
words can't describe how good it really
feels
wow I gotta ask then that was beautiful
what does it mean you've heard Dave say
I'm sure you watched enough live and
give like no one else after you live
like no one else the baby steps allow
you to do that so what does that look
like for you what does it live what's
your next big thing yeah
well we've in terms of next big thing
we've been driving nine-year-old cars
that have about 150 000 miles on it yeah
you need a car I I'm a car guy I've been
very patient
my patient needs to persist a little bit
longer what do we get and people want to
know what are you gonna get oh
something that's new to
but not oh he knows look at it when he
turns sideways you know I like the
Jaguar F-Type I know Dave has had his
job there you go that is a great car the
sound of that car is just a car it's a
it's a wonderful car yeah it was it was
designed by the guy who designed the
Ashton Ashton Martin yeah yeah it's a
beautiful car yeah well done he looks
good I like it do it do it they're a
little hard to find though I'll tell you
ahead of time yeah but they're they're
I've had two or three friends that have
had them they're wonderful that's
awesome good for you man way to go you
guys that's good stuff all right now
when people are listening I know you had
an unusual income which had an unusually
high result also so you know ratio wise
you pounded this thing what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of debt
is uh for myself I would say you really
need to be focused and you need to be on
the same page with your partner uh the
the clarity is is is key I think for me
it's the budget I always use to say that
my budget puts the fun into my funds and
I think that's the intentionality that
you need it allowed us to become
everyday millionaires that allowed us to
to Really laser in on on what our Focus
was
so what's your net worth now
1.8 million
baby steps millionaires debt free house
and everything yeah this is a ding ding
well done Heroes how long have you guys
been married 13 years 13 years and uh
the last three years we've been working
on getting out of debt it was so 10
years otherwise and now you're done and
here we go complete change way to go
very cool and all because of some guy
with the southern Twain yeah on the
YouTube on the YouTube channel that's
that's where it is isn't that crazy this
is where it all happens but it's
beautiful okay yeah congratulations you
guys hey we've got uh the live and give
bundle for you the baby steps
millionaires book you already are one
The Total Money Makeover book you've
already done it and the Financial Peace
University go through it or give it to
somebody on all of those things that's
what the book box is for we want to say
thank you for coming down here so proud
of y'all you're fun to talk to you're
great people your numbers are
horrendously awesome absolutely amazing
very very very well done very good stuff
all right it's Paulo and Elizabeth
Toronto Canada get this 624
000 in 38 months making 290 to 310 house
and everything baby steps 1.8
millionaires gotta love it count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
foreign
[Applause]
I love it that is fabulous man way to go
you two very well done
now you you might not end up in three
years with a 1.8 million dollar net
worth doing this stuff it's possible but
you not might not own an investment
property and you might not have a 310
000 income but wherever you are I'll
guarantee you you can end up there
that's exactly right it might be a it
might be more than three years yeah and
let's not forget I mean Elizabeth had a
little extra woohoo there because she
was the queen of the budget and she just
said at the very end of that if you
caught it she said it was really hard
yes they sold some property which fast
forward to the process but they also
committed to it and driving older cars
and now there's a couple that are very
young by the way and on on their way to
living like no one else giving like no
one else don't miss that I mean it is
doable no matter what your income is but
it's hard no matter what your income is
let me just say out loud it's different
1.8 million dollar net worth you can buy
a new Jaguar yes appetite kazash as well
he just pointed at Dave Dave I heard you
say that she's saying she's saying no we
created a fight that's good no I'm
giving I'm just saying all permission
once you're a millionaire new cars are
okay if you got to if you if you got the
emotional bandwidth to pull it off this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
s
all right
[Music]
foreign
19 21 many are the plans in a person's
heart but it is the Lord's purpose that
prevails
Andy Andrews our friend says when you
know that everything matters that every
move counts as much as any other you
will begin living a life of permanent
purpose
I saw he he does a lot of stuff on
really good stuff on Butterfly Effect
yes comes out of that Mikhail is with us
Mikhail in Oklahoma I'm sorry in Omaha
Nebraska I apparently can't read hey
Mikhail what's up
two years ago when we were in the gate I
would have been out of shape about that
very nice good job
my question has to do with tweaking
um our budget my wife found out today
that she may
um lose her job this wouldn't happen
until November and that's an
aeronautical engineer I'm trying to
stress test start budget
um so my question has why would she lose
her job in November
well the company she works for is I
think in lieu of doing straight layoffs
or making everyone in Human Resources
reapply for their jobs
yeah it's odd she said there's an 80
chance that she won't lose her job but
again I just want to stress test this
and make sure that we uh you know if we
do lose her income
um that we you know can still keep our
four walls going what's she make
she makes 125 and straight salary I make
185 and straight salary I do get a bonus
in stock options which would bring up my
pay uh to around 330 but I don't like to
count on bonuses and stocks so I just
just use our straight salaries as as uh
for budgeting
so you you ought to live on your salary
dude really
yeah so my question has to do with um do
I pull back on
you know 529s for our children and then
oh right now we've absolutely funded you
can't live on 180 Grand
oh we can okay I'm just asking where I
should tweak my budget you should we
I mean you you can do anything you're
doing right now on 180 Grand
can't you
yeah if we
if we don't
put extra money into savings accounts
yeah we can there you go
so if in the 20 chance she loses her job
uh you don't put extra money in savings
until she gets a new job
you're killing me here yeah yeah yeah
keep stacking money keep doing
everything you're doing and you're
already you're already stacking money
yeah like crazy you're making so dadgum
much money is ridiculous awesome way to
go congratulations and how quickly does
she not doesn't she get re-employed
really fast
oh yeah easily yeah yeah nothing to
worry about here so I mean what are you
what are you really gonna lose I mean
you're gonna lose uh one month of income
or something like that and if they do
all that they're probably going to give
her a severance
right yeah I I don't know I I I think
that this is their way of not having to
give people's sentences by making
everyone reapply for a job I I honestly
with what I'm hearing there unless
there's something I'm not that I don't
know uh if I were in her series I'm
looking for a job untrue these people
it's wacky that's a nut if you think
they're trying to figure out a way to
not give people Severance and they're
too too uh uh wussified to just do a
straight layoff because they're broke
uh instead they go through this faux
thing this pretend thing like reapply
look if if you didn't want me just fire
me
you know that's so true why do you have
to reapply so you can figure out you oh
well we wouldn't hire you again well
then fire them I mean my God yeah if I
look around here and somebody I wouldn't
hire them again that means their job's
in trouble right so I mean this is bad
leadership I'm probably out of there for
those reasons anyway but long before
they get a rent let me here I got your
reapply right here's here's my
resignation that's exactly right don't
wait for the shoe to drop the kale and
here's a he's a professional Warrior and
what I mean by that by nature of what he
does well he should be he's God he keeps
airplanes in the air that's right and so
he's not flying an airplane I want him
to be a professional Warrior so it's
okay Michael those are really good
questions but uh you didn't need us as
much as you just need to look at well
what would be what would need to be true
for us to be in really bad shape and
it's just not gonna you don't have a
scenario where you end up in bad shape
you guys are so you're stress tested
okay you're done you're just not gonna
stack quite as much money in your
absolute worst case scenario oh well
you're okay you're stress tested you're
good however you got some uh
advice that you didn't pay for yeah and
that is go ahead tell her go and quit
yeah get another job yeah and and just
say you know I'm going to help you with
this reapplication thing yeah or show up
with an office unless there's unless
they're just wonderful right people and
this is the only stupid butt thing
they've done but I just about guarantee
you that a leadership team that doesn't
have the the uh uh backbone to lay
people off that in a situation where
they're broke and they can't and they
don't they don't have they don't have
the capacity emotionally to do to run
their business that they're probably
making many other leadership mistakes
that are based on virtue signaling or
some other bull crap and so yeah I'm out
of there man I'm I'm betting you I'm out
of there but maybe maybe I'm wrong maybe
it's a wonderful place other than this
one stupid thing but usually this is one
of about 10 stupid things that that
place is doing exactly I'm with Dave
that doesn't just that's not a one-off
that's a really wacky philosophy on how
to lead people it freaks people out you
specialize in that you know you
communicate well to our company you know
and it's like why would you create all
this unnecessary angst for some people
well you got chocolate you got the whole
place on the chopper that's right it's
weird instead of just going uh five of
you are gone right you know uh the rest
of you're okay you know I mean yeah I
yeah it's just good communication and
people appreciated it they they
appreciate bad news yeah more than they
appreciate ambivalence that's correct we
want to know where we stand and uh
that's their leadership lesson for the
day boys and girls tell people even if
it's bad news because here's the thing
if they don't hear bad news from you
they hear it in their head and they make
up crap and it's worse than the actual
reality the bad news boy isn't that the
truth and so that's what's going on with
this whole company when you're we're all
going to reapply I don't know what
somebody read some really bad book yeah
oh my gosh
it happens though all right John's with
us John's in Orlando hey John what's up
hey I can't believe I'm on the Dave
Ramsey show this is so awesome well I'm
honored to have you but I am a little
short on time go straight to your
question sir yep all right so I'm 27
about to be 28 I'm thinking about
popping the question to my girlfriend
who's 30. uh she's going to start
nursing school the accelerated program
next month
um right now she has about 124
000 worth of student loans after the
nursing school program she's probably
going to be sitting in around 150k Mark
um I'm kind of just thinking of what's
the best way to handle the loans with
our other debt and kind of the the best
way to do it after you're married yes
yep yeah after you're married okay after
you're married you worked it at snowball
and she'll be at a nursing school how
much longer she got
uh so she starts next month in August
and it's a 15-month program okay so
you're probably getting married sometime
in the mid during that time I guess or
maybe right after that and
um I was thinking about popping the
question towards the end of this year
and then being engaged through all of
that because she's not going to really
have much time to do anything okay so
she's out she's out she passes her bar
and she's got a good income when you get
married right yeah and how much do you
make
I met about 1 10 115 okay so you're
gonna have 200 000 plus income and we're
going to attack this debt when we get
married and let's talk about that before
we get engaged
because if we can be in agreement on how
to handle money about kids about in-laws
and how to handle the crazy people in
her family and your family that's the
in-law part and about religion those
four things cause a high probability of
a successful marriage be in agreement
about those things before you even pop
the question be talking about them
that's how you know you found a match
good question man good question honored
to have you that puts us out of the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsey Baby Steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]